how's everyone doing
it's a goodie bag it's thank you for
that
it's a goody bag day it's a good day
um related to the goodie bags
um you know once again hello once again
um i want to get these out for you
because you got to have them on a friday
night
there's no real better way to think
about
spending your time on a friday night
then opening up a brand new goodie bag
the topic of the goody bag is um
related to reactions which is the topic
we're starting today but it's really
also related to
uh acids and bases which is something
we'll talk about on monday
so i'm giving you the goodie bag today
but i'll talk about the goodie bag
and and contextualize it in the lecture
on monday
but as i said today what we're going to
do is we're going to start a new
uh topic that we'll be talking about for
the next couple of weeks
and that is the topic of reactions
okay now this falls
under the domain of something called
chemical kinetics
uh which is the study of reaction rates
kinetic move right so
what's moving concentration right the
the stuff that's that's you started with
is doing something and winding up
different that's a reaction okay now
we've already written lots of reactions
in this class
but today we're going to talk about the
rates
uh and and the rate in particular is the
change in concentration of the reactants
and products with time now
so there's a couple of terms that we
gotta know
because we're gonna be working with them
and so i'm gonna start by writing those
down
okay so the first thing is is the the
thing that we're going to talk about
changing which is the concentration okay
so the concentration
is equal to the moles
per liter i mean there are lots of ways
to write concentration this is the way
we're going to write it
moles of a substance per liter well that
has a name for it that's called the
molarity
what's molarity it's moles per liter and
uh oh and then we can also write it in
shorthand which i'll be doing
as simply some substance
in brackets if i say that i have some
substance a
and i say and now i say oh look i'm
writing brackets around it
then what i mean is the concentration of
a
okay that's what that means which is the
moles per liter of
a good so that's concentration what else
well there's the rate
there's the rate and the rate is
as you might guess the change in the
concentration
with time that's the rate that we're
going to be talking about a lot today
the reaction rate there's a change in
the concentration with time okay
what else do we got well we have then
a law because see the here's the thing
the rate
the rate is just the rate it's the
change with something with time right
you know it's like the change uh in
distance with time would be like
velocity okay but what if i wanted to
say well could you tell me
what the rate is as some function
right as some function that's called a
rate law
that's called the rate law and it will
give me a rate
versus concentration that's what i want
out of a rate law and then well i could
integrate that
and you know i could integrate that
because the rate itself is a derivative
with time right it's a change in time so
if i integrate it
well then i've got something called the
integrated rate law
integrated
rate law
and what's that going to give me it's
going to give me the concentration
versus time
right because i so so the rate law is a
rate versus concentration and the
integrated rate law is the concentration
versus time and then we've got arrhenius
let's put it all on the same board so
i'll do one more here
which is the arrhenius dependence
for
reactions and as you might guess
this is going to give me rate
versus temperature
these are the things we're going to be
talking about these are
all the things all these things we're
going to talk about today okay in the
context of reactions i want to get them
all down
on the board so you can see them and
think about them
and feel them as we go forward
so there are a whole bunch of things
that
impact the reaction the rate of a
reaction what is it that matters well
concentration how much do you have
that's the brackets thingy right uh
temperature
catalyst the surface and
and the structure that you're doing the
reaction on the solvent that it's in
though all of these things impact how
the reaction happens you see i grayed
out and made a little
darker those bottom two because i'm not
going to talk about those two but i will
talk about each of those other items
today
that's our goal so how do those items
play into these
dependencies that's our goal to figure
that out okay
so we're going to start with
concentration and we're going to talk
about how concentration
plays a role in reaction rates and we're
going to start with something very
simple
all right i have something called a oh
it's purple
and it turns into something called b
it's green
there you go it's a there's a reaction
okay
so let's start now okay so a
a goes to b b now
the very first thing that i can think
about in this
is that nothing is lost
nothing is lost right so so
i'm going to assume that nothing
disappeared from my container
you see that the container is there so
i've so i haven't lost
any mass i haven't lost any mass well
mass conservation is a big deal
right because so mass conservation
by taking this very simple case mask on
sir oh really converse
we could have a mass conversation too
con that's okay that's kind of what
we're doing
but let's write it as conservation this
means
that if i take away a no
i must add b with the same
amount and not lose anything and if you
look at that in terms of these
coefficients remember these are
stoichiometric coefficients
right right as part of the reaction then
what that means
is that 1 over b
times the change in the concentration of
b with time
must equal minus 1 over a
times the change in concentration of a
with time that is mass conservation just
written
as changes in concentration
now you can see it look if i if i
imagine
just as
imagine that this is one just as an
example
okay one h two
goes to two h
right i'm not gonna lose anything those
are my circular well
okay this this would tell you that the
rate
of this if i don't lose anything would
be
one half the change
in h the concentration of h with time
equals minus the change in concentration
of h2 that's just
exactly what i wrote but with an example
i didn't lose anything right so the rate
of change of this must be twice the rate
of
change of that right stoichiometric
coefficients
come in and they make sure when i write
it this way they make sure
i don't lose anything that's why you got
to have these there
now there's a couple other things about
this right
there's a couple other things about this
um
one is that you'll notice that
um the the rate is is always positive
maybe we should write that up on the top
board because it's a convention
but we like positive numbers when we
talk about rates so the rate
is always positive okay
o is positive so when we have
uh when we're thinking about a reaction
where something's getting consumed
right we're going to write it as the
negative of the change in that
concentration because that's a negative
and then we're going to write it as a
positive
of the change in concentration of things
being formed
okay so the rate is written as positive
um well there's another thing which is
we can go more general
so if we go let's just think about this
if we go more general
more general then
let's have more than just a to b let's
have a
a plus b b
goes to c c plus d
d so now i've got four things two
products two reactants
right okay and b are the reactants c and
d are the products
and they've all got their coefficients
and well so you could look at the change
in any one of these
and know the rate you could look at the
change
in any one of these and know the rate so
so if i look at this
then the rate would be equal to
minus 1 over a right convention okay
it's a positive
value that's got to be equal to minus 1
over b
times the change in b
with time and it must be equal to plus 1
over c
times the change in c with time and that
also must be equal to plus one over d
right times the change in the
concentration
d change dt
right so that
so so i can look at the way any one of
these things is disappearing or forming
and because those stoichiometric
coefficients are there i know
what the rate of that reaction is again
this is basically
a statement of mass conservation
but there's more because this is just a
definition of rate
rate is changing concentration and it's
always positive
done yeah but i want a law
i want to know not just okay yeah i see
how you change with time so that's a
rate
but i want to know a law that if i gave
you any concentration
if i gave you any set of concentrations
what would the rate be
what would the rate be could i could i
come up with a function
and so we write down the rate
as depending on
the concentrations now you can do this
with the products reactions we're going
to do this with the reactants
and so you would have that it depends on
the concentrations of a and b raised to
some power
with some coefficients so k times the
concentration of
a to the m times the concentration of b
to the n okay so we're raising these
now we don't know what these are but
what we're saying is that there's
there's got to be a way if i just know
if you know and maybe if i do some
experiments or something maybe i could
come up with a general function
that depends on just the concentrations
wherever they are
of a and b and they're going to be
raised to some exponent that i don't
know yet
and they're going to have some constant
that's a rate law
that's a rate law okay and so so now
okay now the thing is
that um the rate law
let's go over to here okay so the k
is as you can imagine going to be very
important here that's called a rate
constant
k is equal to a rate constant
okay um and this is gonna
depend on conditions like temperature
pressure solvent so it's gonna depend on
things like temperature
pressure solvent etc
all right and we'll we'll see how this
how you get k
um but m and n cannot come and this is
very important m and
n and k for that matter must come
because in tight from experiments
they're determined experimentally
determined experiment experiments
okay so
you can't this this is a mistake that
that is often
you think m and n must somehow be
related to these coefficients no
m and n is something else i've created a
function
that the rate depends on the rate of
this reaction depends on
i put these exponents in there and i'm
looking for the dependence
on on m n and the only way to do that to
know that is to do experiments
you can't just get that from the way the
reaction is written you can get mass
conservation
and the you know the relationship
between you know
rate rate rate right those are all the
same
but you can't get a rate law unless you
do some measurements
now then when you do then
you can get the order of the reaction so
this is the reaction order
and that's an important that's an
important
uh property
and there's one more thing i'll say and
then what we're going to do i'm setting
the stage here and then we're going to
do examples
okay so so don't worry we're going to go
through different examples
that i think will help kind of
crystallize these concepts
but the last thing i want to say in
terms of setting the stage is that
now the rate the units of rate
if you look at how i've defined the
units of rate it's a change
in you know in concentration with time
so the units of rate
the units of rate
are going to be molarity
over time that doesn't change
right that doesn't change those are the
units of
of rate that's the definition of the
rate
but you can see and we will see that
if that has to always be true then the
units of k may vary
and that's we're going to see that as we
go through examples
so the units of k could be different and
will be
depending on the reaction order which is
basically saying it depends on the rate
law
okay setting the stage now
let's look at some examples and we're
going to go through this sequential
we're going to do a zeroth order
reaction then a first order reaction and
then a second order reaction
okay so zeroth order well zeroth order
reaction
right in a zero so this is nitrous oxide
so this is
a reaction of nitrous oxide turning into
n2 and o2 nitroxide is used in many many
uh applications not just
laughing gas um
and you know so if if we we sort of go
with our
what we just wrote down okay so let's
take this example i'm going to write it
down here
2n2o goes to n2n2
plus o2 okay
well so the rate we know from what i
wrote down the rate
is equal to minus a half
times the change in the concentration of
n2o
with time
so but see now okay so now i'm doing
some measurements
and i'm plotting i'm plotting some data
here so i'm i'm plotting here the
concentration
of end of these of all three of these
the reactant
and the two products with time and what
you notice is if i plot the
concentration with time it's a linear
relationship now what does that mean
that means that they don't depend on
concentration because
the rate is the change right the rate is
the change in those with time
right the change in the concentration of
time it's always the same because it's a
straight line
so if if that's true then
the rate from
let's say straight line
straight line and we'll talk about plots
as we go straight line plot
of concentration versus time
all right straight line plot then we
know
that concentration
is independent
independent
of time i'm sorry
rate is independent okay hold on
rate is independent of concentration
okay so the rate in the beginning
is the change in concentration the rate
in the middle is the change in
concentration with time
and it's a straight line so it's always
the same
well that means something it means
something in terms of our rate law
because now i know from my rate law
that the rate is equal to okay k
the rate constant times n2o
to the m what that's that's from here
right you take all the reactants and you
you put them down and you put exponents
on them
and so i've just got one n2o and it's
raised to the m
yeah but i know there's no concentration
dependence
of this rate so i know that m equals
zero
and it's a zeroth order
reaction our xn oh saves so much time
rxn reaction which means
that the rate is simply equal to k
the rate must equal k okay
so in this case the rate right so we're
continuing here
equals k and that means
that k must have units
of molarity over time
why because that's the units of rate the
units of rate don't change
the units of k will but in a zeroth
order reaction
the units of k have to be equal
to the units of rate there's nothing
else in there
okay again i want to emphasize there is
no
simple correlation between the
stoichiometry you know the coefficients
of these things
and the rate law you got to do
experiments
this data comes here well look at it
there is the mass conservation in action
o2 n2 right you can see it
you can feel it slopes are
different they must be now let's take
our
now here's a reaction some of you may
care about the
but so why does the zeroth order
reaction matter
why does it matter because that's the
reaction
of beer uh yeah maybe you do
so ethanol okay but we'll call it beer
so
what does this mean if i consume
beer if i did then the concentration of
ethanol in it there it is
plotted versus time is linear that means
this is very important
it's a zeroth order reaction it means
if i plot the rate of the reaction you
see it there it is it's a constant
it doesn't depend on the concentration
but that's really has a lot of
ramifications because if i drink a lot
of beer
right the average 70 kilogram person it
takes two and a half hours
to uh for the enzymes in their liver to
decompose
right 15 milliliters of ethanol one beer
but but so but look at that so that
means that if i had more than that
you gotta wait the body can't there's
it's not dependent on how much i have
the reaction of the liver
the enzymes that are breaking this down
is not dependent on the concentration so
if i load up a lot more in there
it doesn't matter there's a pipeline and
there's a rate and it's not changing
well that leads to consequences
to be thought about when you drink beer
but there's another thing we can do with
beer which is we can integrate it
right because if we know
that it you know well if we know that
beer if we know that minus i'm going to
say there's some reaction that beer goes
to something
so minus d beer
right dt okay well assuming has a
coefficient of one
is going to equal that's the well that's
going to equal k
because it's a zeroth order reaction
right it's a constant
and so okay now i integrate both sides
if i integrate then i've got the
integrated rate law for beer
which is that the concentration of beer
is equal to some initial concentration
of beer
right minus kt this
is the integrated rate law that's the
integrated rate law notice what i've
done
i've gone from talking about the rate of
the beer being
you know the rate there which is a
constant to a dependence
there it is integrated rate law the
promise was that would get me a
concentration versus time
and that's what it did concentration
versus time
how did i get it well i had a rate law
and i integrated it and i'm not going
through the math but you know you put
the dt over here and you integrate
okay okay so that's that's an integrated
rate law
well let's go to the next order if i had
first order
and i looked at the data for that then
you would see
if i plot the concentration versus time
it would not be a straight line why
well because for a first order reaction
so now we're in first order
right then if i what so what that means
is that the the exponent here is a one
or if i have two reactants the addition
of them
is it's first order total
or it might be dependent on two
reactants and it's first order in each
of them but then second order overall
because they're multiplied
but let's take let's stay with the
simpler case of just one reactant a
okay so if it's one reactant and let's
suppose
let's suppose a goes to some product
i'm not even going to write it out
now you know that the rate is equal to
minus the change in the concentration of
a
with time right
and that because it's first order it
depends
on the concentration raised to the first
power
that's what we said first order meant
right that's it's
i'm telling you this is first order now
not okay
well you can see that if it's first
order it depends on the concentration
and so that means that you know you can
see from that and you can see from the
plot
if a if the concentration of a doubles
the rate doubles
the rate doubles why can't livers do
that
no they're zeroth order but there are
lots of reactions that are first order
and so you know now okay here's the
thing right now if this is
but the rate still has to have units of
molarity
change with time right molarity over
time
it can't have that unless k's units
are k units in this case
are going to be
so let's see let me write down um okay
uh rate has units
the overall units are molar
molarity over time so now i've got
a k times molarity
that has to have units of molarity over
time
right and so k must have units of one
over time
one over time ah but that
tells us what to plot
it helps tell us things about like what
but the plots
always come better when we integrate if
we think about the integrated rate
law then it leads to
linearity which is something we always
want in plots
linear lines straight line linear lines
really i just said that i did just say
that i'm okay with
it because it's true
but let's integrate this
integrated rate law
so now there's my rate law now i'm going
to take the dt
over and the concentration over and i'm
going to integrate and i get this
a equals some initial concentration
times e to the minus kt
notice the units right one over time
that's good
okay or if you want you could say that
that's a log
a equals log a naught
minus kt and this right now this gave it
to me
right because now you know that if you
plot
log versus time if i have a plot of log
versus time
plot of log
versus time then it's linear and we like
linear and that's what's plotted on the
right right so that's a plot of log
versus time
and so you know you can kind of go
backwards and forth so
if i had a linear plot
with concentration versus time you know
it's zeroth order
if i had a linear plot with log
concentration versus time
you know it's first order and you know
that from
the integrated rate law
now if you have data
how do i know what the what the uh
you know what the rate law yeah sorry
what the
reaction order is often you'll just have
data
you study a reaction and you get data
here's a very important reaction
this molecule is called cisplatin now
cisplatin is is maybe the most
used and one of the certainly very most
important chemotherapy drugs
and but it's not active in this state
with the two chlorines there you've got
to get one of them
out and put a water molecule there
so that with the water molecule it can
it can go and damage the dna of the
tumor that's the idea
right and it can't do that unless this
reaction happens in the body
and so you can imagine that this kind of
reaction is extremely important
what and it's the rate is extremely
important here
right this has to happen in a time frame
that we know very well so this rate has
been studied very carefully
for this reaction and you can see okay
you write down numbers how much
did i start with and and how much what
was the rate
and i'm watching the rate change
right away you know the rate changes as
the cisplatin
concentration changes it's not zeroth
order
right and the second thing you know is
well if you take any two of those and
you take ratios
right then the ratios are the same
so it must be first order that's one way
to know
what order you have right
so if i have data so with data like that
with data you could take you could do
this you could take
ratios
at two different times
and what does that get it gets you the
order
from that you can get the order now
we'll see another example and then
you could go further than that because
then i could plug in data from one of
the times right
i could use data once i know the order i
could use data from one time
from one time
to get k right because
once i know the order i know how to
write down the rate law
and and then i can use any of these
lines to get k
right so we want to be comfortable
with reactions with rates
going back and forth between order rate
law
integrated rate law plots right
integrated right level so so so if i
okay
if i had data that looked like this no i
could do the same here's a here's
another
reaction i said what order is it well
i'm not going to do it i'll just say
so you take any two times in
concentrations and
what you have is that the ratio squared
gives you the ratio of the rates that
means it must be a second-order reaction
it means it must be
right i had something that went into
products
and the dependence of the rate from this
data the dependence of the rate is
is that something's concentration
squared you can see it from the data
so well let's see
ah i'm going back to the middle here
okay so now
we just went to we just went to second
order
and you know so for second order
what do you have well you have that
minus
d of something
some reactant and i'm just i just got
one reactant here
you know you think about it as a right
so the same thing a went to something
okay so minus the change
in concentration of that with time is
dependent on
k times the concentration of that
squared and
if we integrate this one integrate
then what do you get you get one over
the concentration of the something
equals one over
its initial value plus
k t
oh you can see that take the t over here
and take this over there
and then that's the that's going to be
the integrated rate law
and so now look at that what do i plot
to get linear i got to get to linear i
don't like curves
in reaction rate plots
i like linear lines because the linear
line will tell me
right will tell me something about the
reaction order
and it by the way the slope could tell
me something about the rate constant
right and so if it's second order
the plot that gives you a linear line is
one over concentration versus time
all right so let's look so let's say i
had this data and i tried to plot it
well the first thing i do is i say well
okay hold on um
if i plot the concentration versus time
that's what it looks like not linear
that means it's not zeroth order well
then i plot okay i'm gonna take the same
data and i'm gonna plot the log of it
versus time
not linear not first order
but if i plot one over that
concentration versus time
it gives me a perfect linear fit so it
must be second order
plots order linear
okay and and so this is all we know
we're not going to go beyond
zero first and second order because what
i want is for you to feel
your oneness with reaction rates and
kinetics
through these three orders zeroth one
and two
and through these different concepts
that are up there
and if you and so so one more thing you
can do
before i i turn to temperature
one more thing you can do with once you
know the rate law
is you can calculate how long it takes
for the
concentration to be cut in half
right if i know the rate law
then i can ah then i can calculate
the half-life that's what that's called
right
so
so for example if it's first order
let's suppose it's first order then you
know
log then the the integrated rate law i'm
just going to put the two concentrations
on the same side here
a over a naught okay
uh so the integrated rate law gives me
this
it's just what i had before somewhere
okay now but but uh but you can see well
what if
a what if the concentration of a is
exactly half of the beginning
concentration so
when a equals
one half the initial concentration
well then but then this becomes a half
right so so if i want to know
how much time it takes to get to half
that's a good thing to know just in
general how long do i have until
half of this is left well then you know
that this is going to give you log
two right when a equals a half a naught
then
log two equals k
t and we're going to call that an
important
it's not just any time it's called the
half-life
it's the time that it took to get to a
being one half of the initial and the
half-life
so i've got it right i've got it i've
got the half-life
the half-life is a very powerful tool a
number of you may have heard of carbon
dating
this is just a picture of of uh wild
animals
but see but what happens those wild
animals breathe in oxygen
and other stuff from the air including
stuff that contains a spread of carbon
atoms and we know
carbon has isotopes we know about
carbon's isotopes we've already talked
about them
c12 c13 c14 c14
has this wonderful thing about it that
it radioactively decays
and it turns out that there's a certain
concentration of that
in the atmosphere at any given time and
we can go back in history and know
how much concentration there was in the
atmosphere
and we know if these animals are
breathing it in
right we know that they should have that
concentration
at a knot except this isn't
a concentration this is a number of
atoms but it's okay
it still is a first order process the
radioactive decay of c14 is a first
order process
and so because of that we can date
we can date things using carbon dating
very accurately so this is a really
awesome tool that relies simply on the
half-life
on knowing the half-life okay all right
here's a summary that i thought would be
useful
um this is it this is everything we just
talked about before we switch to
temperature
rate law zeroth order first order and
you all like why did i write this all
down
it's all on this page no it's good to do
somebody say yeah
it's good to write down it helps you
think about things so but here it all is
there's the zeroth order first order
second order
okay integrated rate law that comes from
that
the units of the rate constant the
linear plot to determine the rate
constant
right what gives you you know what the
slope of that line is
and then what the half-life would be if
you just follow this for the other two
orders
okay so this is what this is all that we
just talked about the best way
to fill your oneness with this is to do
some practice problems more than what
we've just done
the next really
the next topic now i'm not going to
spend the same amount of time on
temperature and
and catalyst obviously but i want to
mention how these
impact reaction rates we're talking
about how fast
the concentrations change and to do that
what we're going to do
is we're going to use the collision
theory of reactions
and i've just written it down here what
it is what is the collision theory of
reactions
what it is is it says that they occur
when particles collide
why does a plus b
go to c well because things collided
into each other and they got close
enough
or they maybe had the right orientation
so that
new bonds could form or others could
break right
and and the the theory also says that
not all collisions result in the
formation of product and that there are
two factors that matter
the energy of the collision and the
orientation of the particles
so i want to highlight those two factors
right so energy of the collision
we're going to start with the energy of
the collision
and we're going to talk about that in
terms of where do you get that energy
you get it from heat you get it from
thermal
energy which means these things are
vibrating and moving
maybe if it's a gas they're bouncing off
of the walls of the container
that's temperature right how does that
matter
well in order to understand how that
matters we have to understand
we have to think about
this and this is what collision theory
for reactions tells us to do
is to think about a reactant a reaction
in terms of an energy
landscape and an energy barrier that you
have to overcome
okay so here i have this ea
which is the energy that it's going to
take
i need to put that energy in
for the collision to be strong enough
think about it as like well i just kind
of didn't collide
i had a very low energy so i'm below ea
and i can't get over this hill it really
is
you know you think about like pushing a
car did i push it hard enough so it can
go over the hill
right or um or is it just pushed a
little bit that's the kinetic energy
we're talking about
could it get over that hill because what
what we're seeing is that
for this reaction to happen there's some
amount of energy that's needed that's
the activation energy
that's the activation energy okay
so what does that mean well first of all
you should all be feeling something
right now
and you know what i'm talking about i'm
talking about spontaneous
right somebody said it you were feeling
it why
because i'm talking about a process that
has a barrier that is
thermally activated a process that has a
barrier that is normally
svonte arrhenius crickets
crickets and then and then intrinsic
carriers
activated processes reactions
right they have a barrier they have a
barrier
now here's the thing though ea is
typically you know
like maybe an electron volt and we know
that kbt is 0.025 electron volts we've
talked about this before
how is that possible it's the same as
what we talked about before
because this comes this is an average
energy if you put the boltzmann constant
in
to room temperature this is at room
temperature if you put the boltzmann
constant in
at room temperature you're going to get
that small
energy but we know that thermal energy
is a distribution
this is something we've talked about so
here it is again
so this is the boltzmann distribution is
what this distribution is called
and and if i have my energy for
activating a reaction
my barrier for the reaction to happen
shown there with the vertical line
let me see i have two temperatures so
yeah kt may be small but there's some
tail
out there where there is enough thermal
energy there's enough kinetic energy for
this collision
to lead to the reaction
right so so if we so those tails
grow larger and larger the amount of of
molecules that have enough energy grows
larger as
you increase the temperature that is
erroneous
the probability for this to happen grows
that is what arrhenius gives us right
and so here it is map this is something
that
um uh that is in the textbook that you
know it's a nice diagram because it maps
the two together
you got the reactant going to the
products there's an activated complex
it needs that activation energy and over
there we've turned on the side
these kinetic energy distribution plots
so you can see when do i have enough
well when i'm over that activation
energy there's going to be some fraction
of molecules that have enough and that
fraction depends on temperature and that
is a radius and so what we get is that
the rate
the the rate k k the rate
is equal to some
constant a times e to the minus
e a over k b
t and remember we use
k b k b for like one collision
for like a molecule or an atom and
we would use r or
r for a mole
here i'm talking about a single event
one molecule colliding with another to
make the reaction happen so
this is now the this is called the
frequency factor
and it's a constant constant
constant and that's something that
you could yeah you could you could
understand how
this might depend on a combination of
things
but it's it's assumed incorrectly but
it's a good enough approximation for us
but it's assumed to be independent of
temperature so we pull it out and call
it a frequency factor
and it has in it
information about whether these things
really made the right collision or not
that's what a has in it this exponent
you know arrhenius is telling us this
exponent tells me about that fraction
that fraction but a tells me about
orientation so here's an example
here's no plus o3 and on the top line
you can see the no right so the o the
o's are red
and the n is blue and the no is coming
in but it's coming in either way whether
it's
n or whether it's o it's coming into the
wrong oxygen
it's hitting that wrong oxygen and so it
doesn't do anything because the one in
the middle
isn't going to be very reactive
not at least at this temperature but
then you got a different case where it
comes in a little differently
and in fact the nitrogen is what's
coming in and leading the way to that
oxygen
on the end and that leads to the
reaction
so you can imagine now it's not just how
fast they're moving
which is what you know the exponent
tells us
it's how it's it's more complicated
right and this is called a frequency
factor because it's
it's sort of all these complicated
effects rolled into the frequency
of the collision being right not just
the temperature
okay and so this gives us the
temperature dependence of the rate
constant
this gives us the temperature depends on
of the rate constant which is very
important this is not time this is
temperature
right this is a different thing than
everything else we talked about here
which
involved time dependence that's
temperature dependence
okay and finally the last thing and
just to just to show you this is my very
last point
is that you know just like before if i
wanted to run a
reaction and make it go faster one way
just like with semiconductors is to
increase the temperature but i don't
want to run my phone at 600 kelvin
so what do we do we use chemistry
i may have reactions that i want to run
a lot faster
in fact i very often do and what do i do
i use chemistry and those are called
catalysts
what a catalyst does and this this
picture shows it in the context of
collision theory
right i've got these these barriers i'm
trying to get over here it's flipped it
doesn't matter there's a barrier
so the reactant is higher than the
products okay there's still a barrier
that i have to overcome what a catalyst
does
is without being consumed what a
catalyst does
is it's another material in there where
it allows that reaction to happen
with a lower barrier that's what a
catalyst is
and you better believe this is important
so a catalyst lowers that
without changing the temperature and
there and in just 20 seconds here's my
why this matters
catalytic converters is one of the most
important technologies
for pollution that has been invented in
over the last 50 years
it's changed the game in terms of what
comes out of that car
why does it work it wouldn't work you
wouldn't get rid of these things
these toxic things you wouldn't get rid
of them unless you ran it at like a
thousand degrees
and you're not doing that underneath
your car next to the gas tank
but if you put the right catalyst in all
of those reactions to get rid of those
toxic chemicals
can happen much more quickly and
efficiently right
okay have a great weekend see you guys
on monday
you